stacks and smart contracts on top of
bitcoin why is it important to bring
this functionality to bitcoin and then
how exactly does it technically work
bitcoin is decentralized money and right
now if you look at the use case of
bitcoin people are mostly like either
buying and holding it or they're trading
bitcoin on centralized exchanges and the
next evolution of this is when you can
actually do really interesting things
with bitcoin in a completely
decentralized way imagine that you could
trade bitcoin or decentralize the
changes you could participate in lending
protocols where you're lending in a
completely trust test manner earning
interest on your bitcoin you can put up
your bitcoin as collateral and you can
start building all sorts of interesting
decentralized applications that are
using bitcoin as a settlement layer so i
think bitcoin as sound money is the
first step
deploying that bitcoin making it
productive deploying it into smart
contracts and decentralized uh finance
that's step number two and then the last
step is the use of bitcoin as a
settlement layer i think it's a global
settlement layer you want the world
trade to settle on bitcoin you want all
important information on the on the
planet to settle on bitcoin eventually
and the smart contracts for bitcoin are
a critical piece for enabling step two
and step three i think we're on step one
right now and and we really want to get
to step two and step three
got it and when you talk about the kind
of technical architecture uh explain how
this works because i think that uh when
people hear um smart contracts on
bitcoin i see a bunch of people debating
is it on bitcoin is it a uh side chain
of bitcoin is it whatever frankly i
don't know how much important is the
nomenclature as much as just like how
does it work
yes i think the simplest mental model
for this is
you want the bitcoin base layer to be
very simple very durable you don't want
to change you don't want it to be very
complex right you can look at some of
the other
alternative blockchains out there like
ethereum and others and they decided to
make their base blockchain very complex
with smart contracts and that comes with
a bigger security attack vector so the
way bitcoin works is the base layer is
not going to change it's very simple so
it's almost like a two layer solution so
the base layer is bitcoins decentralized
money and then you add some sort of a
additional layer on top that brings
smart contracts and i think that's where
people get into all sorts of different
solutions is it a side chain is it is it
like an l2 i think without getting into
the technical details what stacks really
does is that it tries to enable
fully expressive smart contracts for
bitcoin meaning that anything you can
build on ethereum or anywhere else you
can build that in the bitcoin ecosystem
and developers are rea this is something
that is really resonating with
developers because they see the trillion
dollars in capital that is just sitting
there with bitcoin and they want to come
and build applications on top and can
you give us some high level uh
stats on like how many people are
actually building in the ecosystem
yes so i think uh so what over the past
like six seven months or so so stacks
only went live this year uh we now have
i think 1
300 something smart contracts published
on the blockchain the 10x effectively in
the last three months or so and there
are organic things happening like you
know bitcoin nfts like i that caught me
by surprise there are something like
three or four organic marketplaces that
emerge for for nfts if people are
familiar with open c
uh and then marketplaces like that on
ethereum so that's already happening in
bitcoin and and and there are so many
artists there are so many developers who
are coming in and basically launching
all sorts of different applications i
believe there are more than 30 startups
now in in the ecosystem and these
startups are building things like stable
coins lending protocols like you name it
right like it's it's a really like
exciting time to be around for the smart
contract space in bitcoin